and if you're gonna describe your
professional style in just one word and
I'm gonna hold you to one word what
would that word be authentic I'm here
with Rachel out in front of New York
City Hall or actually maybe hi New York
City Hall and she's the first chief
digital officer of New York City can you
tell me what that exactly entails
absolutely
I'm the city's chief digital officer and
my goal is to realize Mayor Bloomberg's
vision for making New York City the
world's premiere digital city and
day-to-day what that means is that we
focus on improving your user experience
of engaging with the city of New York on
whatever digital screen that may take
place on as well as on speaking and
meeting with startups in New York City
and finding out how we can be even more
of an advocate for them how we can
establish public/private partnerships
and overall improve the lives of all New
Yorkers so as a New Yorker as a citizen
of this lovely city what can I look
forward to so you can look forward to a
brand new revamped NYC gov that's the
city's website that's one of our bigger
projects right now and you'll also
continue to see an expansion of the
social media that the city runs the city
today has over 280 social media channels
Wow we also it's quite a lot so Joe how
do I know which one to use well that's a
great question and that's one of the
first questions that we sought to answer
when we created the NYC digital office
so what we created was the umbrella
brand at NYC gov and if you look for NYC
GOG on Twitter Facebook Tumblr
Foursquare you find the sort of parent
channel for all these different channels
and we curate from across all of these
different platforms we pick and choose
the need-to-know news and the idea is
that as a New Yorker you start out with
those channels and then you can do the
deeper dive once you find something
you're more interested in like NYC
schools or the fire department so if I
tweet at New York city government Lloyd
get a tweet back we engage very strongly
with the public so at 3 1 1 NYC which is
the twitter handle for 3 1 1 so for
people who have don't know what 3 1 is
are
New York absolutely 3-1-1 is the city's
very successful customer service
platform and by and large it's
predominantly via phone although it is
available online at nyc.gov slash 3-1-1
but there have also been a number of
innovations recently that really helps
help New Yorkers to be served and to get
the information that they need and one
of them that I think is extremely
exciting and really the first city
government to do this is that if you
send a tweet at 3 1 1 NYC which is the
handle for 3 1 1 you will receive a
response back 3 1 1 now responds to
every tweet that they get and they will
process your service requests whether
it's fixing a pothole or cleaning up a
downed tree so during we just survived
Hurricane sandy here in New York how did
this social media play out during that a
lot of people needed a lot of help 301
sort of the non-emergency line for help
and there were a lot of people in
non-emergency situations it was socially
useful during that emergency or not so
much absolutely
social media was completely crucial all
throughout Hurricane sandy and very much
a crucial part of our communication
strategy especially when you're looking
at areas where people may not have had
cell coverage if you were able to get
online if you're able to access Wi-Fi
even for a moment you could access some
of these platforms for example Twitter
and Facebook which have a lighter lift
and your computer is easier to load so
what we do in those cases is we set up
an expedited approvals process which is
put in place to make sure that all the
information going out from the city is
absolutely consistent there's no room
for error in a situation like this and
what we found out is that information is
so so very important give you an idea of
the scale of the social media of New
York City how many followers you guys
have on Twitter as how many likes you
have on Facebook can I like New York
City on Facebook absolutely we hope that
you will like Facebook like us on
facebook if you haven't already that's
at facebook.com slash NYC gov and you'll
find a mix of photos you'll find a
digest and summary of every major press
announcement we also ask the public for
their input and we reach out to get
their stories one of the ways that we
decided to decorate and to create the
brand and and sort of the identity of
the pages we held a photo contest called
love NYC and we invited the public to
submit their photos they sent in 2000
photos and we had the public also vote
on the winner and that became the the
art that you'll see there so in terms of
numbers we now have a total digital
reach including our website of about six
million uniques per month Wow and on
social media alone we're pretty close to
three million that's impressive you look
across across our channels and it's a
really exciting platform because city
agencies are able to directly
communicate with constituents to very
quickly rectify or correct information
that may not be accurate and it's
transforming the way that city agencies
are able to inform and serve the public
so I I heard rumor that I'm gonna get
Wi-Fi in my parks is this happening has
it happened have I not been to a park
recently you may already have in your
part so there are over 26 parks in New
York City that AT&T has provided
completely free Wi-Fi to and in addition
to that there is a number of additional
parks that are being rolled out through
through negotiations that the city has
brokered with Time Warner and cable
vision so we see these as great
opportunities to get more people the
access that they want and really
reimagine the way people enjoy public
spaces is Wi-Fi coming to the subway
Wi-Fi is on the roadmap to come to the
subway there's actually a pilot
happening right now on 14th Street on
the west side close to 8th Avenue and
your Google suspiciously yeah Google is
is the sponsor of that Wi-Fi I believe
that on sixth Avenue there's also a
Wi-Fi pilot that's sponsored by
Microsoft and there is a plan to provide
Wi-Fi in all 277 underground subway
stations this is of course managed by
the MTA which reports up to the state
but we're in close contact with them
because it's very important that we
share information so how does one get
such a cool job what did you do before
you were chief digital officer here for
New York City so before this I was an
entrepreneur I founded a citizen
journalism platform called ground report
and I also had a digital strategy
consulting practice and worked both in
the private sector and in the public
sector and basically I saw this role
advertised online on a blog on business
insider to be exact and I thought it
sounded like a very exciting opportunity
I mean I I Love New York City it's the
greatest city on earth
and
led at the top by a technologist and an
entrepreneur I really couldn't imagine a
more exciting opportunity